I'd like to introduce J Kim who will be
speaking about hot water leak detection
using variational auto encoder model so
let's please welcome J hi everyone my
name is so cheeky
I'm a senior data scientists today I
will talk about the hot water leak
detection using variational to include
another before I start I want to know
how many of you hear about the
variational - encoder anyone can you
with okay that many I was actually
really worried it how to explain this
one more easily because the concept is
not simpler and then it's really a
complex mother so you might be really
boring but I'm not really fun person so
I tried to make it easier to everyone so
let's start now
so our - first of all I will talk about
how why hot water leak detection is
important and I will talk about like
background of the dis mother and also I
will explain about the variational -
encoder and how it works and what it is
and also I will talk about our team
actually we tried to detect the hot
water leaks from the our dataset so we
tried many approaches I will introduce
top toast approaches and then one of
them is actually the variation of the
encoder so why operation which encoder
can be served or things that are the
other things Cruden is reserved
these are very specific regions our
introduced about there and also I will
talk about the wizard from the each the
approaches and see if which one can be
actually the best solution and our
conclude this talk after day so why hot
water leak detection is important
because total dick it's not happening
just a one day is actually happening
gradually a little part of the bleeder
so it's very hard to notice in the
beginning so we have well it's actually
getting growing and growing and Etienne
is getting really serious so when I
become really serious we cut noticed and
then we try to fix it but it's too late
because it's hot water leak is already
huge huge and the face serious so we
have to actually fix it and it cost a
lot of money so the cool is that we
tried to detect the hot water leak
before something happened so when it's
really small
we don't matter we started with the
matter which cannot reach detect the
small leaks and also we actually
screening like all the meter meter data
API and we tried to detector like
custody from the profile data was
something and then once we found we
actually analyze data system water leak
they will send the people and then let
them we shall fix it well if we sent the
people to Rome trace or wrong wrong time
then it's too late were like and also we
have to send a picture and we have to
pay them so it will be costly really bad
so all the regions is actually why we
helped actually the detect the hot water
leak or in the beginning so people we
start how aware the data is come from so
we have a lot of meters of each
individual houses and the meter is
actually acquiring the data every hour
and then it's stored to our main system
database API hourly so the data is
growing very fast and they also is
really huge you can see there a 4.3 I
want three billion unique hourly
he stood every at our last 30 days you
can see how big the data is in also 3.39
billion our grid is collected up all day
so we have a really huge dataset
yeah so we take this data we tried to
detect the hot water leak and then this
is actually what we tried we attempt
many ways so with a consumption data we
help our that we can actually plot
profile data and then we see if we see
like some no more patterns then we we
send the people and check it like in
fosston this is still going on it's very
manual process and then it's very easy
to be wrong so we actually send the
people and check it in person that means
we we pay them it's a lot of money
secondary or we try that anomaly
detection so for example with a
distribution we check the p-value and we
checked all the 5% age of the population
and see if the hot water leak is
actually included in the heart or are we
actually did our clustering with dot we
crossed out the data and then tried to
detect outlier and then if we track each
chart to see if the hot hot water leaks
included in the outlier but essentially
tried it but it doesn't work thoroughly
in the third totally or we try many
machine learning models and also deep
learning models to predict hot water
leak but our explain later but usually
the general general motion no negative
learning didn't work in our dataset our
I explained to you why later in the
fourth we have a text data so the
technician put like each houses and they
write down what they found like what
they smell what they saw and then the
text data is actually included in our
the main sister so we have some text
data so we built our text mother or
predictive mother and then tried to
predict the water leak based on data
text but this model worked pretty well
but instead the technicians don't go to
the individual house every day they
don't go every hour
so take we'll go to the individual house
it's a once in a while so if this mother
canopy actually automate the solution
for us but all things that this model
can actually help us to label more the
water leak water leak labor so we still
using it usefully for this is not the
thesis of topics our postponed to next
time yeah so this is a what we actually
changed so this is the region right no
more machine learning active learning
didn't work in our dataset we have a
like bitter data but a metadata meter is
not necessarily same type of the meters
and also the old emitters are
manufactured by TIF phone company so the
quality of the data or the property of
data of each emitter is limited form so
we can actually actually use do more
machine learning because this one like
we actually all the meters at different
and then we have as a subset of the
labor and then the label data has from
the deformity meters so auto model for
most is working differently with a
different data in different meters so
this is a very big problem in secondary
to attribute of the features that we
have is not much related to the hot
water leak
label so this is a typical tour deep
learning problem because machine
learning or you need a really good
teacher or to train where and build a
good mother but all the features are not
really correlated
so Apple is cool it a little bit but
it's not much so it's a typical tip
learning problem
totally now we have a huge data stay
really big but the data we label data we
have is very small so we so we are
actually manually labeling one by one
but our the resources are really limited
so it's almost impossible to label all
the data that we need so this is another
big biggest problem that we have and
with top lastly some important features
like the construction the column that is
including some the newest in it so
without actually cleaning up the dead
lock picture actually we can actually
expect aqua to start but this data is so
much and also yeah we can actually Dino
is everything just manually so so the
try we actually trying a different way
interpolation auto encoder is one of
them so this is a chamfer so we have a
different type of the meters in appear
the different area instead all miss stop
but we are actually collecting the data
from different area from different
meters and they will label it yeah so
the red circle heart is actually what we
cut and we know is what early or not we
actually label it but instead we don't
know other part of the data and then we
are missing out a lot of totally and we
don't know so the the same for theta is
natural representation of the older data
so if we build a model like just general
general matter without the temporal data
and then if you try to predict like the
yellow part actually we did initially
collector yellow part
then the material is really cannot
predict the yellow because we never
never teach them so it's just a general
general the approach of machine learning
deep learning doesn't work yes so so
here like I want to talk about what is a
variational to encoders and then how it
works so just three categories just main
category of variational to encoder so
firstly people know the operational to
encoder is a generative model so for
example issue is this mod is used in
image lot so if the image has like
missing part like the regeneration of
the image is not good enough then this
matter I should generate missing part
building in and then it actually makes a
higher resolution of the mother I mean I
mean time image so it's very famous
actually you can check out from the
internet very easily what our data is
not image but we actually apply in
different application secondary
operation auto encoder is unsupervised
learning and also same is for supervised
learning as well so many people are not
familiar with the same ease focused
learning in my opinion so semies focused
learning is in between between the
unspoken stony and focused learning so
spaced learning model require totally
older label data to train the model
unsupervised learning mother doesn't
require any labels
same is for vessel only mother require
the label data and the own label a top
post so sugar our talk about the son
later
so it's trained to support differently
that label data and label data
separately and then it actually
optimized
laws for failure and actually combined
at the end and it applied that loss
value to
different like mother so this actually
same is Provost learning so ta mother is
actually a misplaced learning so we have
a limited of limited amount of the label
data and then we have a huge amount of
the unliberated own label data so we
utilized on Labor Day educator to
predict hot water leaks so this is a how
it works and then totally the variation
within cutter is probabilistic model so
probability model is actually taking
into account the element of the
randomness of the likelihood so it's not
even though we don't have the data
actually probabilistically here actually
appreciate appreciate the
unknown variables in a likelihood way so
our explained tostones in the later
slide so this isn't me to see also
instead a variation of Tanqueray is a
used in the image online so i just chose
my picture which is a theta
but accurately test notice so so
autoencoder
is a deterministic model so this model
actually taking the representation of
the data as deterministic value however
the operational tinkerer is different
this one is taking the like
probabilistic distribution from the the
data so even though we missed some parts
like from the metadata is actually like
you make to some probabilistic
distribution and is actually make the
consideration which is not known
variable however this one also
- instantly after day so from that from
that the probabilistic distribution this
matter between essentially so tempering
is taking the appreciation from the
distribution and then iterate and then
when this one is getting cross enough
then the matter is okay so more cross
really will go to more deeper concept so
axis actually no more size of the data
and then we are trying to observe the
hidden zipper ZZZ variable party so we
are actually Q means is the same thing
so we are sure getting q z given x from
the actual data and then we actually
understand the hidden value and then
after that are you scaring going back to
do more size so in the middle part is
the latent space and then what I mention
is much smaller so he is actually
confessed all the representation of the
data in the little space so they
actually by distribution
expo is dividing each classes in the
middle part and then after that is going
back to normal size but you can see
there is a px given ex a given Z so that
means it's a probability it's actually
going back to normal size so if there's
a lactam missing part based on this
probability is - okay building in the
missing part with that so this is how it
works in the rest of people are saying
like encoding model including parts
especially
assured recognition matter so because in
the middle part middle layer you can
actually recognize which cross this
which so
encoding mother
a layer essentially recognition matter
and then recording mother is kind of
generative model because it's generating
the data so this is a sure same thing
but just wrote in mathematics with
mathematics so the reason why we are
actually doing Q Z given axis actually
it's more accurate to be P z given x in
the instead of q z given x but the
region instead you say if you want to
calculate the PX or you have to actually
calculate integral calculation and then
it's not only one variable we have are
so many variables we have are like three
hundred features on board and there so
you have to apply three hundred
integrals like in one time so it's
computationally very difficult
time-consuming so instead of actually
applying the p z given x UI should be
applying q z given x and then if we
actually we just kept between p0 given x
and chill z given x if we say small
enough you say then in ten minutes this
very similar is the same almost then the
matter will perform very great so the
training process is kind of reducing the
gap between px given ex and q z given x
so you can we can actually write our
equation y dot pattern so care means
cairn is ka relative versions it's a
very famous two equations to curve back
our labor
divergence equation is kind of checking
the measurement of flow distribution so
if this is small enough then this model
is performing okay so when you train we
see this value and this value is
included in the loss function and
the lowest value is the small enough
then we know this matter is actually
learning really good so yeah so this is
another multi care
so the de que el means is a KL
divergence and then you can write this
equation to the right and you can
actually derived the bottom part and
then evidence lower bound is pretty much
for this matter so you drop the k TK air
then and then lower bound so you have to
put bigger ego dentists and you can see
derive the the part in the equation so
if you actually with just evidence the
lower bound no sorry if you actually
maximize the evidence the lower bound
that means you're actually minimizing k
diversions so it's the same thing so we
actually try to apply this equation in
the neural network and then so if you
consider the loss function is actually a
prick actually having the elbow the
equation in the loss function together
so this is another way of the expression
so the operation of the encoder have we
we parameterization trick that means the
Z is not deterministic node so we are
actually changing the deterministic node
2 also if the probabilistic node to the
deterministic node and then you can just
simply express that Z is mean plus the
variance multiplied by error so error is
not deterministic so is changing but the
street is becoming deterministic so it
allowed to calculate or faster in the
easier so allowed a propagation of this
matter so so this is actually the things
that I was is prey is
training 1 the picture here so variation
autoencoder is getting the mean value
and variance and then does it actually
do instantly so you make the
appreciation of the actual date actually
yet
and then it's close enough then you're
going to the decoder and then generate
data so this is another integer water in
color is not the probabilistic auto
encoder is deterministic model but
variational encoder is probabilistic
model so you can see what to include
origin actually do anything with the
data is just flat in what it is but
variation what encoder is actually with
a k' air divergence is carrying more
lawn war and war and institute make him
more smart and actually make more better
generalization see ya so so now i will
talk about what we did for detecting the
hot water leak in our dataset so we
tried like a general approach like
deterministic motion money murder and
also tip on your model so we try random
forests and also ma MRP for tip
non-ahmadi
and then another after that we approach
we try be a mother on the first approach
it's just a generative model and
secondly we try be a model with the
machine running so we try to identify
the classes in the latent space in which
applied emotionally in the latent space
and then lastly we try famous for which
provides learning so we actually apply a
model
separately to label data and also also
on label data optimize the
lost lost value and then we combine that
and then we apply that optimized lost
value to MLP and then we classify okay
so in general approach yes we expected
because our data is not same as the
other data Tomasino knee and hip loan it
didn't work they were so even you know
that random voice is really powerful
machine learning algorithm but not in
our case so you can see the accuracy is
about 72% with window forests and MLP we
just got 62 percent accuracy so and then
we try to optimize more about dodging
cool better so we try I'll be a mother
just the first one we just try
generative mod derivative the function
of the pvat mother so we put the data to
30 a mother and then we we let let it
generate the data after 18 in the enter
output we cut the label and then we have
a visiting Labor the old scatter Hui in
there so in the missing part which also
generated what it is it was a generate
data and then you generate a some labor
as well
so we compare that with the testing data
set labor and see how accurate is also
this construction features actually most
correlated for for our dataset so we
just try her luck generate generated
consumption column and then we we just a
label
classifier or powerful as rhetoric and
data below is the non metallic and then
we compare with a test data so in also
we tried many other districts we some a
bit of the features
idea and then we heard it and then we
compare and also max we try max in
alchemy accessor the results wasn't that
great but the third one with the
constants and eita it wasn't that bad
comparing other unlike general
approaches for spear is not great either
so we tried a different approach
so in the middle layer who says the
recognition area not in the latent space
is very easy to classify with the some
machine learning class fire in the
middle layer so I was thinking we were
thinking sure it lets you apply like the
SPN butter and also KNI mother and then
see if we can actually classify Daleks
Kjetil research was really good so
especially - okay any mother was
actually classifying the water leak
really successfully so the approach we
try and let's say miss Provost learning
so we actually applied to different not
labeled and so label data on label data
in different a P PAE mother and then
optimized lowest value and then we
actually combine those and then we
applied to the inert matter and we try
to classify the water leak we are still
working on it so it's not minor it's
getting better but which my design still
lowest it's not easy to help a parameter
changing because the earlier term others
is actually we assume that the
distribution is Acacio but this one is
known because the label data and all
label data is different
so we have to she replied
do you call a distribution which is a
mathematically more challenging so so we
are still working on it but we are based
on the I should paper world shown R T so
I should perform the best so we are
expecting it might be better than the
earlier approach Canaan no sir we're C
so this is summary yes so when the first
an MIP didn't work they were and then ma
trust like some machine learning
auto approach was actually working very
good
so this donkey is a really promising you
can actually produce a nice in the
future the m2 mother is a stem is fast
running we're still working on it but
you might be better than the earlier one
so we actually keep working on it and we
might get results
maybe soon so this is a conclusion so
yeah so our dataset special case of our
dataset is not working just like other
general models so we need us more
special way to classify our leaks
yeah so PA mother is actually really
really good and it's actually improved
on that a lot of the performance so
right now we are actually doing very
manual process with what early detection
but it's possible to automate this
process without this model in our
opinion sir yeah touch it so this is a
references if you are interested or take
a look and any questions
[Applause]
can you highlight what features you are
using for your work and white is not
correlated I'm sorry could you repeat
okay yes so you mentioned about the
metadata so what features do you have oh
yeah so there's the consumption data is
one of them the constant consumption is
the guest consumption of of the all the
individual houses and is a factor hour
which is the way into meters that you
recorded and also there's Iraq Nobita
size in the meter type two thousand
fears and temperature and humidity
humidity and there are more so it's
about three hundred something yeah and
when you deploy their model to
production what was the result was it
able to detect the lake for customer
effectively or do you still don't know
yet sorry could you repeat yeah what was
the result when you get the model now
you put up two productions in production
yeah we didn't organize yet our year
plane to procure nice soon so it was I
waited it and our little
okay
hey it's I don't really have a question
it's more of a suggestion I know that
back in the day when they would have
probably still do power lines and they
would try to detect if something
happened to a power line they would look
at the impedance and use physics based
models to try to understand the systems
so I would just recommend looking at
like energy grids and that kind of
system to see how they detect similar
issues that I imagined they would have
yeah I think it's good point yeah
actually this model it's not only for
water leak detection you can detect
other stuff as well so so some case that
you cannot get order representation of
the data this Marty will help because
this is a probabilistic so even though
you don't get whole representation or we
actually find the hidden variables and
then we collect more appreciation which
we don't have so yeah you have in the
energy or axon electricity I'm pretty
sure
over there
so you mentioned one of the problems
that you face is you have very low
amount of labeled data yeah where are
your modal's performing better if you
were testing them on training and
testing on label data only and also have
you looked at any other ways of
collecting the additional labels and
it's good point yeah so if you have a
more label data is better you know it's
a more labor data small representation
and we have initially trained better but
comparing our whole large data set so
it's impossible to label everything so
we are trying to get a more label data
we need how many of our team actually
working on the labeling it's a very
manual process
we need a label more yeah have you
looked at they may be calling so the
data from the home insurance companies
that actually pay for fixing those water
leaks yeah I heard it is very expensive
to hire some labeling company yeah but
our case is the more special because
even we hire some labeling company they
don't know our pitch in this case and
they also cannot do export so basically
we have to do that but but our to export
is not many so just a few people data is
growing every day so it's very hard to
labor everything so tutorials you're
thinking about this model this model
will appreciate what we didn't label yet
so so this is why we are doing this
any other questions
yeah I think this actually talk is silly
difficult encoder is medicine for matter
but yeah but it's a plea to actually
show here and maybe just a introduction
but if you have a more question just
email me anytime
our I just hit apply and then there are
many different applications with PE
mother just like this is just one of the
use case but you can apply in the image
you know so it's very famous so these
are another generated mother coated or
chained in such ein but is not actually
generating same data you can actually
manipulate to take two different image
but very matter which is generating same
data so for our use case we have to
detect leaks so we use a P PAE
but if you are actually in entertainment
industry and it's a good to discover
about GAE GAE and martyrius a baby so
yeah so any other questions okay thank
you very much Jane let's give him
another round of applause thank you
[Applause]